hi guys it's Silbert again and before I
start with the actual video I want to
make a couple of things clear so this is
basically being two boards to play
rollercoaster 3 I ditched rollercoaster
v2 as well and installed rollercoaster
tycoon
one and took the challenge to complete
every single scenario but but make the
park look as good and realistic as I
could so basically I'm going through all
of the original roller coaster tycoon
run scenarios and show all of the parks
that I made in the way that I made them
and how and all that kind of stuff now
this is something I want to say because
the quality of this video is probably
not going to be too amazing that's
because I could roller coaster tycoon 1
in windowed mode to be able to have the
highest quality and the least amount of
pixelated blur that I would normally
have but I had to sacrifice some
computer with it whatever well think
basically what happened was like spikes
like spikes everywhere and glitches is
why I spent the video up slightly I cut
out some parts but sometimes it still
glitches but the point that I want to
get across is how my parks looking what
I did and that's basically what I'm
going to do so enjoy right so coming up
as the first pike forest frontiers well
this is probably something that most of
you recognize it's that simple park with
well lots of simple empty space and you
can do anything and win this scenario so
for me it was quite a challenge to make
it look good because he had only one
year only 250 guests and not too much
money I'm actually in a depth right here
because I make that little pond right
there because I wanted this to look at
least somewhat ok and of course there's
a shuttle coaster sorry for that but
moving on from to the next bike just
quickly correspond to you it's not that
important or
cool in anyway this is dynamite news and
I've got a couple of cool coasters right
here like this corkscrew coaster I had
to kind of end it in the middle of the
track but it's not too bad then there's
this woody which is which has a station
on top of the hill just like the
corkscrew coaster got a chairlift going
over there and it made some helixes and
other simple stuff
then there's the Tacoma slash arrow
flying thing that you just saw and I'm
trying to get a better view for the
coaster yeah right here so that's
actually the thing that I'm most proud
of and actually the thing that I ruined
two years on I think I started working
on that as my first attraction that was
a really stupid idea but I really like
the final look of it at least it's
something nice that you can do with that
ugly hill in the middle of your park
that's kind of an obstacle to many
people but I you know I like it it has a
decent speeds very nice stats makes me
lots of money actually so it was a huge
investment cost caused me a lot of time
and money but in the end I guess it's
worth it and then in the corner you can
just see the small little junior coaster
and a little overview of my park
now the next park is leafy Lake and I'm
not too proud of this one this looping
coaster is kinda cool though but it's
not too specials just a standard looping
coaster with two loopings
very swatch coffee Trek and
it just goes in and out and out and back
or whatever you call that's some weird
airtime males then there's the monster
coaster which is ridiculous I had no
idea why I did this but I just felt like
making a huge wooden coaster so this is
what I came up with not too much of a
big fan of this I kind of like the
helixes at the end but then again this
coaster is kind of weird and maybe too
big and too much in an empty space but
oh well it made me money so whatever so
then the rest of the park is just a
little senior rail flying coaster and a
shuttle coaster right there again sorry
for the shuttle coaster but sometimes
I'm just like earth money I need money
so yeah because money can sometimes be a
really big problem when you're building
parks like these because coasters with
scenery just cost so much money that you
have to sometimes build a shelter
coaster just to get money I didn't
though I didn't never ever even plan to
build attractions to get money and then
delete them every attraction that I
built has to stay though so that's why I
did as well and that's the end of the
Outernet Coast which i think is
so-called crayon craze which is a
terrible name my names by the way are
absolutely terrible on this bike I think
the shuttle loop Coast is called full
load yeah basically moving on to the
next part this is my favorite part from
the original series of course it's
Diamond tights amazing Park
I just love claustrophobia and
agoraphobia
I had to reduce their car count to one I
mean the Train can't because they're
otherwise they would crush but yeah
here's my little inverted coaster it's
not too big it's not too fast but still
on the stats are off the chart and then
there's the wooden coaster really fast
but actually has a really good start it
starts and I might say yeah basically
- nice ghost is but the thing with
Diamond Heights is you don't have too
much land left and it's hard to get
is to with all the pets and stuff like
that so it's kind of hard to make some
nice coasters and I used this area for a
bobsledder thingy so that's pretty nice
by the way weird thing I've no idea why
I did that but I think I got about 50 of
those gardening I even know what you
call them in English because I need to
play the game in English on the I did
play the game in English well then I
totally lost the word for it whenever
you handy handy man that's why I meant
basically I got like 50 of em for this
park and ice and I assigned almost all
of them to mow the grass I've no idea
why I did that's what I guess it looks
funny I have no idea but yeah that's
basically Diamond Heights I didn't add
too much more I did add two underground
coasters which you could see right now
and the kind of sneaky I just wanted
them to attract more guests and get the
park value up a bit because it's I
wasn't entirely sure I would reach the
park value of 20,000 you have to have I
think so that's why I just added them
and then we've got evergreen Gardens
which is not too special but it's got
one monster of the mini steel coaster
and that's this one I'm not entirely
sure what it's called again but it's got
to lift tails it's got helixes airtime
Hills amazing at well I guess it is I
shouldn't say that above my own post
well anyway it's it's pretty cool and
it's very long
so basically lance and I kept all of the
original sin scenery that's my idea also
one of the things that I wanted to do
was to keep all of the original scenery
and as much as the original rides of the
parks as possible to keep their looks
and just kind of work around them with
the coasters so that's why I kept all
the scenery and just try to do stuff
with it like that coaster that steel
mini coaster I just made it go along the
trees that were already there and same
kind of goes for these attractions
especially these mazes because they used
to be
mace Masons out of real paths spot so
yeah guests would get lost in them so
that's why I built these attraction
mazes things so another standard looping
coaster I'm sorry for all the standard
looping coasters but I just felt like
every old self-respecting part should
have a Schwarzkopf so that's why I built
all these things plus watch Gogh is
amazing so why not
plus they look awesome let's see enough
reasons for me to build just watch golf
coasters everywhere and I even built a
monorail on this bike because it was so
huge and it was a way to spread out to
be well practical but yeah I didn't
really care too much for that Yankee I
did find that really nice spots for the
young for the carousel merry-go-round
thingy oh and then last but not least
actually built this right as the last
thing as well because I've got that one
hill and it was full of scenery and I
had no idea what to do with it without
actually ruining it so that's why I
decided to just build a very small mind
train it's not too fast it's not too big
it's just a small mind train it's not
really anything else this is a realistic
mind train for once because of the my
trains I've seen a roller coaster tycoon
one maybe two as well not well not too
because you've got the six flex bikes in
there but they're all well ridiculously
fast and large and unrealistic probably
and this one is actually pretty
realistic except for the water part I
mean as soon as though what I love is
going to ride
to coast is gonna get flooded well that
thing is just doing his thing and going
through the helix is slow as hell which
is quite annoying but whatever looked
good so yeah it's the next Pike bumbly
Beach which is actually totally crazy I
suppose I mean there's literally no
space less than this Park at all I just
built things everywhere I actually had
to hurry in the ants to build everything
I just rushed it but it doesn't look too
bad it's kind of that Blackpool Pleasure
Beach kind of idea that I wanted to get
including the single roller coaster
actually which is pretty cool
and yeah we've also got that bobsled
coaster and a I'm spinning too much some
steel mini coasters I actually removed
that old wooden coaster because it yeah
wasn't really too practical so I built
two coasters in the place for that and
we've got the Big Dipper and the small
Dipper so Blackpool Pleasure Beach
circles all finished
never mind moving on it's a conspiracy
basically so we've got the the thingy
drop also known as the the waterslide I
think in roller coaster kun one and
corkscrew coaster right there which is
kind of cheating because I've got a
booster on top otherwise it'd be a
little bit too slow it would actually
make the track but it didn't look as
cool so that's why I added a booster
boosters are pretty cool and then
there's the on the right photo just to
get money so then there's Trinity
Islands which was really a challenge for
me because I don't want to cram it too
much but there's really not a lot of
space I mean there's not a lot of space
on the land I mean there's plenty of sea
space but not land space and not going
to build on the sea do need map where
I'm going to do that as big pier but
I'll show that later on so I've got a
standard steel mini coaster that you
just saw and the single real flying
coaster thingy which a which I actually
haven't seen in real life
it's seen them but they're not really
like coasters anyway a little mind train
right here which is again quite a
realistic mind train I think it's not
too fast it's not too slow it's kind of
a family right at which I think mine
trains are supposed to be and then
there's the invert that I somehow
managed to cram into this place with a
family slide thingy and a pirate ship
which was I had no idea how I did that
and I actually really liked the ending
of this inverted coaster it's got a
corkscrew slash inline twist at the end
and that's the shuttle loop coaster
which is actually the one shuttle loop
coaster that I actually like and I
actually didn't build it for money
whoring reasons I just wanted to have a
very cool entrance to this island so I
figured maybe I can build a path through
a looping and that worked out in the end
so that's how I built that so next Park
is Mel's world which is that Pike that
starts out with that weird invert coast
and that bobsled wait this is not even
melt what what the hell this cadiz world
it's the it's the other world this is
the one with the Chris a looping coaster
which is kind of inspired by revolution
in Six Flags mm-hmm color scheme hmm
trains and looping Schwarzkopf it's
about aside from that of course it's a
very original ride very creative no but
I just like the look of it so I figured
it really fits into the park and got
some nice airtime Hills it's really long
actually kind of it doesn't drag on too
much but in the end it does lose a bit
of speed which is a bit unfortunate
but I wanted it to look as good as
possible and this is what I got now the
one special thing that I did with this
park was actually turn storm instead of
removing it like a smart person would I
got rid of some trains and I actually
built a coaster next to it and made it a
racing coaster now this is actually
pretty cool at least this is something
that I enjoyed making and I enjoy
looking at it's just I don't know it's
refreshing to take one of the pre-built
rides and actually add another ride to
it to make
a racing coaster especially with storm
because it uses almost all of the little
space that they bought right there just
a built storm him so and that was pretty
cool and they actually sync up kind of
well the only thing now I had to do with
kind of not have to synchronize stations
the kind of one space apart just to have
them synchronize at the top of the lift
Hill and then of course there's just a
small steel mini coaster because every
party needs to steal mini coaster
without that you're not a good park you
don't have any fun anything for the kids
I suppose then I'm looking at the park
rating which is like nine nine nine
which is which it should be and then
this dinky park Oh God dinky Park is
terrible holy [ __ ] there's no space in
this park you have to buy everything I
decided to leave the but leave the park
land with all the attractions that was
already built and the beginning of this
map I decided to just leave that
untouched and start all over again on
land that I would buy so that's what I
did got a huge loan got huge depths got
huge money problems just to buy all that
land and then I built a cup of coasters
that actually worked kind of well
especially with that woody going
underground and got all my money back
just before I had to get that certain
company value or whatever you had to do
for this bike think of six late guests I
have no idea but ninky bike was annoying
but the one thing that I actually liked
about this part because the coasters are
not too good because yeah
space reasons is this looping coaster I
somehow managed to get a decent again
looping Schwarzkopf coaster in here with
two loopings and a standard layout with
the helix at the end but still it's
dinky Park so I was really happy there
I'm somehow managed to get that in there
and then there's a way to themed and
packed away bumper cars that somehow
looks pretty good I have no idea how I
did that but my guess it's a total waste
of space but moving on we've got aqua
park which is that park with annoying
water rights that nobody likes and the
one was a slide that always crashes or
get stuck and the only space that I
really had left in here was this little
space which I decided to build a mine
train in now this is the one mine train
which is kind of over-the-top and really
fast and really big it does have lots of
tunnels though and they say that my
trains do need lots of tunnels so I
guess I got it right there and I guess
in the end it's not too fast it's not
like storm fast and it doesn't crash and
it makes lots of money so that's good
but basically what I did with this bike
was what I did with that input right
there I built three coasters including
that invert that you see right now
underground just to make it look decent
without cramming the entire park and
just added a couple of flat rides and
shops and stalls above the ground and of
course toilets because there's no
toilets in this park it's really stupid
and I think there's a steel mini coaster
underneath a log flume yeah there is
that was really hard to get in there and
then underneath the waterslide there's a
corkscrew coaster which actually act or
actually has two corkscrews and the
launch so that's pretty cool and the
waterslide is running great right now
which is
funny special and then we've got
millennium mines and this was not as
good I mean I've got a couple of decent
coasters in here but there's a huge
depth the park rating that's not even in
death what we're talking about the park
rating though is terrible and it's like
750 or something and that's not too good
I mean it's not it's not terrible
terrible but for me it felt like it's
not in the 900 not near 900 so it's bad
but I've got a couple of decent looking
coasters even though the terrain here is
terrible I mean I only like grass this
desert is okay but this this dirt I
don't like that my train looks decent
though again ridiculous mine train with
an enormous drop with lots of speed it's
kind of crazy I think in this Park I've
got a looping shot okay sorry for the
shot a coaster that my train coaster you
see right there the crazy invert which
sucks ass it's terrible it looks really
good but it's got an intensity rating of
over 10 a corkscrew coaster which you
see right there which I'm going to show
right now so in that corkscrew coaster
this just does its thing I suppose it's
not too fast it's yeah it's a decent
ride it's not great looking or anything
but it's not bad either it's it's not
like that invert which looks awesome but
it's actually a pain in the ass and
actually he nearly kills people I
suppose
so that corkscrew coaster just does his
thing does its thing with the mind
training the room in the background and
then we've got the weird wooden coaster
and the shuttle coaster and moving on
this is actually mouse world I was
confused but this is actually melt world
which is actually one of my favorite
bikes which I managed to build because
as you can see this part has got plenty
of rollercoasters and especially that
crazy mine train which I just showed and
the game is totally glitching out I
don't know where that's happening but
basically I've got that awesome mind
train in the background right there
which is really big and yeah it's gone
okay that was nice okay moving on man
we've got multiple Mountain which was
apparently some people call this one of
the hardest scenarios in the game I
didn't really mind it that much I mean I
barely even bought land for this I just
built a cup of rides a cop off coasters
and it was enough to do whatever I had
to do for this scenario as I figured I'm
not going to cram any more I didn't
build a shuttle coaster again but yeah
it's a crammed park what do you expect
but I was really happy to get that arrow
family suspended coaster in there which
looks pretty decent and then there's the
Jr coaster as well now this is Pacific
pyramids which is also glitching out for
some reason that's great but basically
I've got that looping coaster in the
middle right now on the mountain I've
got this diving machine and this input
and the game is going crazy that's
that's nice and then there was the
junior coach then then it's gone
well at least I'm glad that it works on
crumbling woods because this is my
favorite I think yeah this is the part
that really looks good
forget about mouse world forget about
Pacific pyramids this is the park that I
really like I've got the arrow whatever
you call those things again right there
and that was the wooden coaster which
was way too fast glitching again then
there's the dueling coaster that's kind
of a agoraphobia / claustrophobia
coaster nice little woody right there
quite a big steel mini coaster actually
but yeah I really like this bike for
this course we've goes to right here and
of course the the racing agoraphobia /
claustrophobia inspired looping coasters
because they actually really worked out
in this park which was surprising I had
to remove the racing wooden coaster for
this though but the racing wooden
coaster that was already here it kind of
sucks in my opinion so yeah this crumbly
worse if you don't know it comes with
really old rites and they're like 14
years old and you can either remove them
or replace them and I decided to remove
them and replace them with something
entirely different
well now here's big beer which is not
interesting so I'm going to skip this
real quick but I just wanted to make
this not look too messy so I decided to
go with three flat rides and three
roller coasters and I somehow actually
make the scenario so yeah that's that
moving on we've got lightning very
lightly well a lot it's really hard to
pronounce no it isn't stupid basically
okay lightning Valley I'm pretty sure
that's the name I'm I don't have a sheet
right here but you get to the road so um
this was actually pretty hard because
weird terrain terraforming annoying
everything is basically this is an
annoying part because the terraforming
is really annoying just hills everywhere
is no flatland you have to remove trees
everywhere people are getting lost and
stuck in the park because there's too
many paths when you start this but it's
also a perfect challenge for some
awesome terrain hugging coasters so
that's what I decided to go for we've
got this terrain hugging steel mini
coaster and as you can see actually it's
a terrain hugging waterslide I normally
rarely built what slides but this one
was actually yeah this one was actually
pretty cool it looks cool it's actually
got a great rating and
it just it just does its job I suppose
now we've got the wooden coaster which
is not too special there's lots of
underground stuff it's not too
particularly amazing above the ground
I think the looping coaster is actually
the best ghost in this park and I did
actually manage to build some flat
rights and in the beginning but yeah
those aren't too special now this is
ivory towers now ivory towers for some
reason is one of my favorite parks and I
have no idea why it is because you start
out with with this park and there's puke
everywhere all of the lights and the
benches are demolished by the guests and
the part rating is zero I'm not even
kidding zero out of thousands so you
have to get this Park and completely
rebuild it from the ground up so I
decided these coasters that they already
heard they're pretty fly but get it fly
because it's a flying no nevermind
basically they were pretty cool but I
decided to remove them and replace them
with four coasters on my own but I did
kind of keep them in my heart because I
kept the colour scheme for the looping
coaster which which replaces the
suspended coaster that was already there
so we've got this stand-up coaster and
the looping coaster that you've already
seen and the suspended coaster that
you've already seen and the enormous
corkscrew coaster that functions as a
hyper coaster but since we've got no
hyper coasters in this game it's a
corkscrew coaster that's basically a
story behind that and they've often
they've all got a white track just to
hint at that old flying coaster that I
remove that was already here which
actually was ridiculously intense and
yeah I really like this Park especially
the look of that looping coaster I
really like
how I just I don't know it just fits in
there I have no idea why but to be
honest the graphics and wallah casse
takumin one are also very nostalgic and
the graphics on this looping coast
I just they really fit into any scenery
but moving on we've got the next part
which was terrible for me this was
actually the hardest challenge I suppose
it doesn't look too good because there's
one why actually two restrictions in
this park
and these two restrictions in this park
are the one are the two sections or the
two restrictions that make this Park
incredibly hard
not hard per se if you want to spam the
water but if you want to make it look
like a decent looking park then yes
they're going to you're going to hate
them basically you can't remove any
trees and you can't remove or you can't
do any terror forming so I was stuck
with the terraforming and the trees that
were already there so yeah that's really
hard because you work you got to work
around the trees with the paths and the
and the flat rights well that's still
doable but doing the coasters is
ridiculously hard
so yeah this looping coaster which
usually doesn't loop through a looping
but whatever it looks decent was
actually I guess one of my better and
coasters in the spike because they're
all kind of terrible what I didn't
expect too much of it
the junior coasters are kind decent
though because yeah junior coasters
aren't too big and you can have small
curves and all that so that those were
decent but moving on this is the very
last scenario of the game Thunder rock
and the idea that I had for this park
was to build flat right around the side
of the rock because basically you're
left with empty thunder rock with the
chairlift leading to the top of it and
it's one big stone basically it's one
big slab of stone
I got a build with it so I got flat
rights on the sides of the rock near the
cliffs and there one big looping coaster
in the middle and some roller coasters
on the side of the cliffs just because I
wanted to kind of make those cliffs look
a bit less boring and bland and I had to
get something to attract the guests to
get I think if you need to get to like
thousand guests for this park which is
quite a lot for the size of the park so
that's why I just kind of had to cram
without cramming too much and there's of
course the immensely huge mind train
because those are you need that you need
a big mind training every park just like
you need a big steel mini coaster and a
looping coaster of course again generic
swatch got looping coaster with two
loopings
but this is one of my favorites to be
honest so yeah that was it that those
were all the scenarios played by me I
just did a challenge to make them look
as good as possible
and I guess they're okay I don't really
care about the end result anymore I
gotta say doing this was absolutely
great like it's my entire childhood
coming back to me and reliving
everything and nostalgia everywhere so
maybe there comes a time that I'm going
to be bored of rollercoaster 3 again and
I'm
to go to this game again or maybe I'm
going to install corkscrew cut a
corkscrew follies and loopy landscapes
because I've got the disks right here I
just didn't install them yet and
actually play those scenarios but for
now I'm going to get back into roller
coaster tycoon 3 and music and other
stuff
life basically well see you in the next
whatever video bye